Belarus has supported Russia since the start
of the war in Ukraine. It s provided weapons,
military bases and logistical support.
But is that support set to escalate
into something more active?
In Belarus society there is a consensus that
we don't support this war, that Belarus army
should not participate. Lukashenko also
feels it, also understands that if he
sends out Belarus troops to Ukraine, they can
defect, they can turn arms against him.
That's from my guest today. Franak Viacorka
is chief political advisor to Belarusian
opposition leader Sviatlana Tsikhanouskaya. She
claims to be the national leader of Belarus,
but how legitimate is her claim? And
how successful has her opposition
been to Alexander Lukashenko's regime?
Franak Viacorka, welcome to Conflict Zone.
Hello.
Mr. Viacorka, over the
weekend you had Russian Defense Minister Sergei
Shoigu in Belarus meeting his opposite number.
And just a few days before that you had unnamed
Russian generals arriving in Minsk as well for
various meetings. Is Russia planning an escalation
of the war in Ukraine with Belarus's help?
The visits of Russian generals and officers are
usual things since Lukashenko came to power.
But when war has started, all the deals that
were signed became secret. And we don't really
know how much independence, how much sovereignty
remained in the hands of Lukashenko in the hands
of Belarusian people. We believe that every
visit they decide on given Belarus unit or
Belarus sector of military complex under control
of Russia. Shoigu s mission to visit is also
important because it happened just after the death
of Minister Makei, the Foreign Minister, which was
very close to Lukashenko, and it was perceived
by Belarusian officials as their reminder
who is in charge. So Belarusian officials,
Belarusian officers are afraid of Moscow.
I do want to talk about the death of Foreign
Minister Makei, but first I'd like to talk
about what these visits by Russian generals
mean. You have, for instance, described as a
very dangerous development reports of Russian
missiles, including hypersonic missiles and
fighter jets such as MiG 31s being stationed
in Belarus. What is the information you have?
Is Russia planning large scale air assaults
on Ukrainian infrastructure from Belarus?
The last missile strike that we have witnessed
was on November sixth from Belarus territory.
So it means already for two months there were
no strikes from Belarus. But for the same time,
more than 10,000 Russian soldiers arrived
to Belarus and they're deployed in different
parts of our country. They're passing
military training. Along with the troops,
we see vehicles. We see some tanks. We see
some divisions of air defense systems arriving
to Belarus. It doesn't seem they're bringing
attacking group of army on Belarus territory.
It seems they are bringing their army in
order to control the situation in Belarus,
in order to fix the Russian occupation
of Belarus. We really believe that Russia
can use Belarus as a consolation prize in
case if it will lose the war in Ukraine.
Are you worried that Belarusian troops might
be thrown into the fight in Ukraine?
It's still very likely, but not next two, three
months. Right now, Russia doesn't have enough
capacity nor weapons nor vehicles on Belarus
territory. Belarus army itself will not be able to
conduct such operation. It needs strong backup,
primarily technical backup from Russia. Also,
Belarusian soldiers, they don't have morale.
They don't see Ukrainians as enemies. In Belarus
society there is a consensus that we don't
support this war, that Belarus army should
not participate. Lukashenko also feels it, also
understands that if he sends out Belarus troops
to Ukraine, they can defect, they can turn arms
against him. There will be split of elites. There
will be new wave of protest. And he's really
afraid of sending Belarusian troops to Ukraine
because it will, it can cost him the power.
So you're confident that with Russia's back to
the wall in Ukraine, essentially losing the
fight, falling behind on the battlefield,
as Jens Stoltenberg, the NATO secretary
general, says that President Putin is not
pressuring Alexander Lukashenko to commit his
troops into battle. You're confident of that?
I think they are playing the role. It's the
performance. Lukashenko is playing the independent
leader who supports Russia, and he wants to stay
exclusive ally for Putin because this is the only
way to stay in power, to have guarantees that
Putin will not come to murder him. But also for
Lukashenko, Putin is very, very important right
now in order to control the internal domestic
situation. To say that Putin is not pressurizing
Lukashenko, I think, let's imagine that this
is the leash and Lukashenko is the dog on the
leash. And Putin is trying to shorten this leash
so much as possible, to not allow Lukashenko to
not leave him a space at all. This is the goal
of Putin, to create the puppet regime, satellite
regime, which will be doing 100% of everything
the capital Moscow will want from him.
So you had said in November that Putin
was not interested in sending Belarusian
troops to Ukraine. You stand by that?
Yes, Yes. I think it will create more problems
than benefits. It's not experienced army. I was
in the Army. I was serving in the military on
the border with Ukraine. It was ten years ago.
But I know what is it. Lukashenko invested
in KGB, in the secret services that that aim
to protect himself. But he never invested
in Belarusian army. When Belarusians will
receive this mobilization calls, there
will be huge protest, huge resistance.
Because society doesn't support this war at all.
And Lukashenko probably told Putin about this.
Also, Lukashenko use the legend that Putin, if I
will send my troops, then the Poland, Lithuania,
Latvia will attack me. Because you see, they
are preparing, they escalate. They deploy more
troops on the border. So he used this as the
reasoning in order to not send out Belarusian
troops. So they play this performance. Everyone
is happy. They create the pressure. They create
the pressure on Ukraine, constant pressure
that this might happen. And I think that even
the threat of sending out Belarusian troops is
to distract a big forces of Ukrainian army.
Help us understand Alexander Lukashenko, the
current leader of Belarus. Would he rather be
on the side of President Putin or would he
rather be with the West, for instance?
He will be with Putin because Putin is
mentally close to him. Lukashenko is the
Soviet man. He is very anti-Western democracy,
something that goes against his principles,
against his nature. He chose Russia and Putin
instead of Belarusian people in 2020. He could
agree on dialogue with Belarusian protesters
two years ago, but instead he called for
Putin's help to suppress this protest. And
right now, we see the tipping point of this
pro-Russianism in the head of Lukashenko.
Now, in October, Alexander Lukashenko told
NBC in an interview that no one was closer to
President Putin than him. Do you read that as
a signal to the West that he was ready to mediate
with President Putin, between President Putin and
the West to curtail his dependence on Russia?
Lukashenko just want to stay relevant,
to be important. He is, you know, this
like alpha man. He wants to be the first
everywhere. This is why he was so happy
when the first Minsk negotiations took
place in 2014 and Lukashenko hosted them.
Lukashenko wants to be the big player. He
wants to be in the first league and also all
the statements about his closeness to Putin
about nuclear weapons in Belarus in order
to raise the price, to raise the worth of
himself. But usually it's just a bluffing.
He is very poor, old, weak, insecure man.
You talked about the death of Vladimir
Makei, Belarus s foreign minister,
a close confidant of Alexander Lukashenko. Did
Russia have anything to do with Makei s death?
Possible. Everything is possible right
now. We can't exclude any of the versions.
We still didn't see the publication of the
document about the death of Makei with diagnosis.
It's very strange. It's one week passed, but
still, there is no official information. Also the
statement from Lukashenko about the death of
Makei appeared many [days] after the fact was
revealed. It means there is something behind
it. We see that the Belarussian officials
are very threatened. They feel that they
can be the next and they think this death
could be could be just death. But also
it can be part of the bigger events,
bigger dynamic, we still can t see.
You talked of Russian troops in Belarus
there to, quote, control the situation.
Is Belarus a hostage of Russia?
Belarus has [been] taken hostage [by] Russia
and [by] Putin together. These two criminals,
they just use Belarus territory in order to attack
Ukraine and to revive the empire. And not just
Belarus, but Belarusian people are taken hostage.
Let's not forget that there are thousands of
people in jail. Hundreds of thousands were forced
to flee the country. In 2021 when a crackdown took
place against Belarusian democratic forces, it was
a preparation for Russian war against Ukraine.
You talked about the pro-democracy movement.
Let's talk about that. Last week, opposition
leader Maria Kolesnikova ended up in intensive
care after she was transferred to hospital from
her prison cell. She was perhaps one of the
last major opposition figures left inside
Belarus. Would you say her fate is a big blow
to the opposition movement inside Belarus?
Maria is a big inspiration for many Belarusians,
especially Belarusian women. She became a symbol
of resistance. She was leading these massive, huge
rallies in August and September of 2020. And right
now, when we found out she is in the intensive
care unit, it was the big shock to all of us.
Was it a big blow? Of course it was a big shock.
Was it a big blow to the opposition movement?
Yes, it was. It was. It was a blow. It was a
blow. But also, we have to investigate what
happened to her because just before ended
up, ended up in the hospital she was put
in the punishment cell. This is the KGB style
torture cells. People are without fresh air.
People are without communication. They could
be beaten there. And something something
happened wrong to her. Perhaps there was an order
from Lukashenko personally to punish her.
Doesn't all this show that the opposition
movement inside Belarus has been silenced?
No, it's not silence. It changed the form of
resistance. There are many partisan groups. They
work in every region of the country. Most of them
participated in stopping the Russian trains. They
conducted sabotage on the railways in March and
April this year. There are thousands of people,
members of the cyber partisan groups, they are
paralyzing state infrastructure. And a few weeks
ago, they hacked the Russian Oversight Committee.
Roskomnadzor leaked the data to journalists,
and there are many activists who put Belarusian
or Ukrainian flags all over the country. We
see also mass disobedience campaign, not
all over the country, but in big cities,
primarily when the workers of the big factories
refuse to do their job, for example.
Let's take that at face value. But hasn't
that invited a greater crackdown against
them from Alexander Lukashenko?
It is indeed. Indeed. And we see right
now the repressions bigger than in 2020. Every
day from 10 to 20 people are being detained and
people not just detained, they are tortured,
they are harshly beaten. More activists die
in prison. And this shock a lot. And we call
on the international community to react. We
call on the UN to take urgent measures.
Let's talk about numbers. The Belarusian
human rights group Viasna claims as many as 5000
people are in prison due to political reasons.
They are not classified officially as political
prisoners, but they are in prison because of
their political activism. The United Nations
says hundreds of thousands of Belarusians are
leaving the country and going to neighboring
countries. My question to you therefore is:
who is left in the country to carry out an
opposition against Alexander Lukashenko?
Belarus is 9 million people country. So
the protest took more than 1.5 million
participants. So even if, let's say, a few
hundred thousand Belarusians left the country,
still we have a million to resist.
Also, there is a big disappointment,
big willingness to change the situation and
to prevent Belarus from participating in this
war. So I think people who participate in the
resistance right now, they did not participate
in 2020. There are new people who reacted on
the fact of the war, and they resist right now,
they're on the front lines and they go out
and they protest despite all the terror.
You are based outside of Belarus
as an opposition. How effective are
you? How many people, for instance, has your
movement been able to release from prison?
We are in daily touch with Belarusian groups on
the ground, with local communities, with media,
with bloggers, civil journalists who spread
this printed samizdat leaflets, putting them
in mailboxes. Sviatlana Tsikhanouskaya, leader
of Belarus, who won elections - She created the
united transitional cabinet, which is like a
government in exile, and which gives a lot of
hope and inspiration to people in the country.
We know all that. We know all that Mr. Viacorka
but then how is that helping activists inside
Belarus? You admitted earlier that they keep
getting thrown into prison and that crackdown
has only increased since 2020. So how is your
work outside helping them inside in Belarus?
So we pass assistance, we try to pass equipment
where possible, we conduct information campaigns
to counter Russian and Lukashenko's propaganda
primarily, but also to inspire Belarusians
to fight. We try to keep the morale high,
to build connection between different
groups, different partisan groups within
the country. And we can lobby for more
international support for Belarusians
who are still fighting in the country.
Is it not a failure of your opposition
movement that after 2020, at that time when
there were massive street protests and it
seemed that the game was up for Alexander
Lukashenko, he has been able to hold on and
continues to govern Belarus. Is that not
a failure of your opposition movement?
Not yet. As we see, the crackdown in 2020
was preparation for the war. Lukashenko
wouldn't survive without Putin. It's Putin
who provided him with money, with soldiers,
with the resources back in 2020. And right now,
Lukashenko is paying his debt back to Putin.
It's not a failure yet, but the situation
became much more complex. Now we are part
of the bigger regional geopolitical crisis.
Now we are fighting not just for democracy,
for democratic elections, but we are fighting for
very existence of Belarus statehood. And in order
to get Belarus free and independent,
we need the victory of Ukraine.
Sviatlana Tsikhanouskaya, your boss, to whom
you provide political advice, emerged from the
2020 elections and particularly the protests,
the mass street protests that happened after
that. Now she presents herself as the leader
of the Belarusian opposition. Is she?
I think she is a national leader of Belarus and
president elect, who won elections but didn't take
her office because of Lukashenko and Putin.
Is she the leader of the Belarusian opposition?
I think she is the leader of Belarus nation
because Lukashenko is in opposition. She
got more than 70% of votes, we
should call her the president.
So she does not lead a united
Belarusian opposition?
She's leading the United Democratic Forces.
Exactly. She united all the major groups,
traditional political parties and the new
groups that appeared in 2020. And of course,
there are different ideologies, different
views among different politicians. But
she's absolutely the unifying figure to all of
those who see Belarus free and democratic.
Let's see how unifying that is, because an opinion
poll by Telegram based pollster Narodny Opros
among opposition minded Belarusians, found
that the Kalinouski Regiment of Belarusian
volunteers fighting in Ukraine was five times
more popular among Belarusians than Mrs.
Sviatlana Tsikhanouskaya. Clearly, she's not
a leader of a united opposition, is she?
This is the pollster just among activists of this
specific group. And Kalinouski Regiment is just
the group of military volunteers fighting
in Ukraine. So let's not compare, you know,
political leadership and fighters. And let's not
forget that Sviatlana Tsikhanouskaya participated
in elections she won elections -
multiple observers, surveys, polls,
internet voting proved that she won elections.
She received [inaudible] 3 million votes.
So the Kalinouski Regiment is
irrelevant as an opposition group?
Kalinouski Regiment is the part of the democratic
and independence movement. They are fighters
in Ukraine. They are fighting for liberation of
Ukraine, and they are they deserve a huge respect
and we fully support everything they do.
Would you say they are popular?
They're not popular as politicians. They are
popular as soldiers because they sacrifice their
life in order to save Ukraine. They understand
that when Ukraine wins, Belarus wins as well.
So they are not seen as a part
of the opposition then.
Now they're fighters. Let's let's divide the
politicians and the fighters and military
volunteers who serve in Ukrainian army. Of
course they are, they are playing a very
important role. And first of all, they save,
they preserve the good name of Belarusians
who were seen by many Ukrainians as aggressors.
And Kalinouski Regiment, they prove that not all
Belarusians are like Lukashenko, that Belarus
regime and people are two different things.
Right. Let's talk about Mrs. Tsikhanouskaya.
You keep saying in this interview that she's
the national leader of Belarus and
she herself keeps calling herself the
national leader of Belarus. But who, except
for Lithuania, agrees to call her that?
Almost in every country she comes she's met
on the presidential level. In the parliament,
she's always addressed as Madam President -
today, just in one hour, she meets Prime...
There is no, there is no, but there is no official
recognition of her as the leader of Belarus.
There is de facto recognition. There is the
level of protocol which defines her as the
head of state. There is no legal recognition
because it will take years. And we don't have
these years. We don't we didn't go into this game
of legal recognition, we see that she is met...
But it s more than just a game, isn't it? Because
Alexander Lukashenko's regime continues to have
diplomatic relations with a lot of countries,
particularly those in Asia and Africa,
for instance. There Alexander Lukashenko counts as
leader of Belarus and not Mrs. Tsikhanouskaya.
That's true. That's true. And this is the
problem for us, because these nations, then
they come to the United Nations General Assembly
and they vote very often in support of proposals
of Lukashenko or Russia. Yes, that s true: This
is why we are trying to reach out to countries
outside of the European Union. We already reached
out Latin American. We have some some relations
there. We reached out to Africa, Southeast Asia as
well. But a lot of work to be done. But the most
important in terms of economy, in terms of trade
and political relationship, of course, is the
European Union, where Lukashenko is not recognized
as the leader. And now we are asking we are
calling and recognizing him as a war criminal.
Now, Mrs. Tsikhanouskaya has also sought to find
common cause with Ukrainians. We began
this interview talking about the Ukraine
war. Let's talk about the Ukraine war. She
has said, and I quote, There cannot be a
free Belarus without a free Ukraine . Does
Ukraine see it in the same way as well?
Yes, I think Ukraine sees it a little bit
different. They see Belarus as the guarantee
of security, of safety, because when Lukashenko
stays in power, there will be constant threat
to Ukraine like it happened in February, February
this year, Lukashenko promised that there will not
be attack from Belarus territory and suddenly
this attack happened and Russian tanks almost
reached Kyiv from Belarus. Ukraine understands
the importance of having a good relationship
with Belarusian people. We have 1000 kilometers
common border. And right now we are trying to
build this relationship again. We are trying
to coordinate our activities and to work to
coordinate our activities on resisting Russian
occupying forces. Situation in Belarus and Ukraine
are different, but we fight the same enemy.
One final question. Mrs. Tsikhanouskaya hasn't
yet been able to meet President Zelenskyy.
When is that going to happen?
Yes. She didn't met officially, only informally
at one of the public events. It will happen when
there will be willingness of Ukrainian
side. But she has very good relationship
with the Verkhovna Rada, the Ukrainian
parliament. We have good relationship
with Ministry of Foreign Affairs. But we
understand why Ukrainians don't meet her.
They don't want to provoke Lukashenko.
Is it also because they do not trust her?
No, I think because there was
a clear sign of Lukashenko:
if Kyiv will meet Tsikhanouskaya, Lukashenko
can escalate the conflict against Ukraine or
even introduce troops. So for Ukrainians right
now, the most important to minimize the risks.
When will Ukraine recognize her as
national leader of Belarus? Officially.
I think it, if Lukashenko introduces
troops, Belarus troops to Ukraine,
these processes will be speeded up and then
Ukraine can recognize Tsikhanouskaya and
meet her. But right now, they're
very cautious. They don't want
to play with fire.
It's been a pleasure talking
to you. We'll have to leave it there.
Thank you so much for joining us today,
Franak Viacorka.